so I've been playing a lot of legends of
Zelda breath of the wild since I got my
switch and when I say a lot
I mean it's damaging my relationships
and business I'm obsessed and that's led
me to ask myself what is it about breath
of the wild that makes it so compelling
why are so many people infatuated with
this game right now so how to think and
I believe the answer has something to do
with the reason that we're drawn to
action movies comics and even working
out as well I think that we can trace
what the new Zelda gets right all the
way back to the very drive that pushes
us towards the venture and challenge
it's the same human spirit that's
summarized by Joseph Campbell's hero
with a thousand faces sounds grandiose
for a computer game but let me explain
[Music]
so according to literary theorist Joseph
Campbell every single story in films
books comics legends myths and yes even
games is essentially a retelling of the
same tale that tale is referred to as
the hero's journey or the monomyth and
while different examples of fiction
might veer from the structure more than
others
most will still make the same critical
stops along the way these stages include
the ordinary world the call to adventure
refusal of the call meeting the mentor
crossing the threshold tests allies
enemies approached the inmost cave the
ordeal the resurrection and return with
the elixir so during the first stage the
ordinary world will find our hero in the
normal environment and get to know what
their life is like while things are just
okay at this point usually the hero will
experience some kind of pull or desire
for adventure often the hero feels
somewhat out of place like they don't
quite belong this is a call in itself
but often it will be compounded by a
catalyst of some sort the discovery of a
mysterious trinket new information about
themselves or their world or quite often
the death of a parent in superhero
stories the hero will often receive new
powers
at first the hair will be reluctant to
accept this challenge they'll turn down
the offer of adventure and need further
persuasion and encouragement
this is refusal of the call often the
hair will meet some kind of mentor maybe
an older man figure they'll give them
words of encouragement and perhaps some
kind of trinket or weapon that it can
take with them to help on their way
this is meeting the mentor and in some
cases it will happen later in the story
crossing the threshold is the point at
which the hero accepts the road ahead
and embraces the journey sometimes this
will literally involve crossing a
threshold into a world of adventure
other times it will be a less literal
decision to try something new or take on
a challenge
repeating we're not in Kansas anymore
tests allies and enemies describes the
initial challenges faced in this strange
new reality often this means meeting new
allies and facing initial challenges and
obstacles that aren't too hard to
overcome
but they give a taste of this new world
eventually the hill will make progress
on their journey into the strange new
world and they'll begin to uncover its
core this is often described as the
inmost cave the belly of the beast as it
were and the most dangerous and crucial
part of the challenge the ordeal is the
biggest challenge of the hero will face
and one that will often leave them
battered and defeated it's at this point
that we normally see the end of act to
the point where all seems lost for the
hero what did you say to the kid it
ain't about how hard you hit it's about
how hard you can get hit
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the next stage is where the hero turns
things around sometimes by accepting a
higher cause or having a personal
epiphany often there will be a literal
transformation and my favorite example
of this of course is Goku's
transformation into a super saiyan of
course this theme is also seen very
commonly throughout religion and myths
with many messiahs literally returning
from the dead only stronger and more
formidable than before in other
instances the hero may receive a reward
of some sort such as an elixir a weapon
knowledge or love this may be the
MacGuffin that motivated the hero to
leave in the first place
or it might be something unexpected
finally the hero will journey home and
return with a newfound power and
confidence completing the coming-of-age
story they'll often face down an evil in
the home territory and may face a
parental figure in order to become their
own person and mature into an adult they
are now masses of both worlds of course
sometimes this elixir is loved in which
case they'll likely live happily ever
after
so these themes are universal because
they speak to our unconscious desires
and commonalities in particular they
speak to the aspects of our psychology
that are shared across all of humanity
as vestiges of our evolutionary history
it's no coincidence that Joseph Campbell
was influenced by the psychologist Jung
who suggested the existence of a shared
collective unconscious Jung too pointed
out the recurring themes across culture
history and works of art in the form of
archetypal characters so we respond to
this universal story because it is the
story that we all shared when Humanity
was in its infancy we would all have
been born into small supportive tribes
and then would have been forced to
venture out into the world to discover
pastures new and new resources would
have battled with monsters forged for
food and become stronger and more
formidable in the process and this is
still a story to a degree we are still
forced at some point to leave our home
and to make new friends to decide what
we want in life and to grow as people
and we all strive for actualization that
point at which we feel we found purpose
and peace for more my many years writing
about health fitness and neuroscience
what I've learned is that a human body
and mind crave this challenge and you
expect
our body is constantly changing and if
it's not taking on new challenges and
having new adventures then it's moving
backwards it's up to you if you want
your body and mind to grow or decay this
is why the brain releases a reward
hormones like dopamine and serotonin
when we successfully accomplish a
challenge and it's why it becomes more
plastic when we try to learn new
subjects this is why we're more like to
enter flow state when we're an entirely
new environment and when it comes to
learning the brain much prefers learning
through action and doing rather than
reading and theorizing we crave physical
challenge and our bodies yearn to climb
and jump that's why I find it so
offensive that when we climb something
in public we're told to get down
Drucker's keep on park chorong so you
see this venturing out into the wild
outdoors might not have been
particularly comfortable or safe but it
is what our bodies are designed to do
and we still crave that kind of
adventure mystery and survival this is
where we get our urge to go out and
explore the world now and to take on new
challenges we could stay in our comfort
zone but then we would not progress
forwards as individuals or as a race if
we did not all share that call to
adventure then which humanity be where
it is today or what we won't still be
living in caves we choose to go to the
moon not because it is easy but because
it is hard this is the best part of the
human spirit and it's what exists in all
of us it's why we will continue to do
great things and it's why we will become
overweight depressed and mentally weak
when we don't venture outside our
comfort zones this is why I think Zelda
is such a home run for Nintendo it
manages to capture that feeling of
challenge of having to think on your
feet and discover amazing new things
perfectly when you play breath of the
wild you are living out that hero's
journey whether you're questing through
thick woods trying to find food to eat
and taking shelter from the storm or
whether you're finding the master sword
and using it to return to areas and
battle enemies that you couldn't fight
before
and it perfectly evokes that sense of
awe and wonder when he discover an
amazing new environment and this is no
coincidence either
shigeru miyamoto says that his original
inspiration for The Legend of Zelda was
playing in the woods with his friends
and going on adventures as a child even
the setting and the name alludes to that
original feeling we would have got when
we had to survive in the wild cooking
things to eat foraging for food and
stalking our prey Zelda breath of the
wild when you realize that while being
chased by an enemy you can drop a
combustible material to use as a trap
that's precisely the kind of quick
thinking that our brains thrive on that
makes them grow and develop
Zelda works because it gives us
challenge discovery in adventure even if
it is just a simulation the brain needs
that adventure and challenge to be happy
if you're not finally going calling or
striving for your own discoveries then
you won't be fulfilled
so forget comfort and focus on making
your life a grand adventure that way
you'll be happier and healthier in the
meantime at least we have games and
movies like Zelda and others for a
little bit of escapism and this by the
way is what the bionaire is all about
it's about becoming faster stronger and
smarter
it's about constantly challenging the
body and mind the new ways to keep it
growing and by doing so I think that we
can all of life's that a little bit more
like the lives of our heroes whether
that means discovering new ideas through
coding and philosophy escaping the
streets below by climbing and jumping
across rooftops or escaping the 9 to 5
so we can work throughout the world
that's the other thing I like about the
Zelda games they all serve as a perfect
metaphor for training and how it relates
to freedom and possibilities all of the
experiences you have in Zelda
make you stronger just as they do in
real life and the stronger you become
the more environments you can tackle by
increasing your stamina you can climb
higher by improving your combat you can
bencher through land swarming with
enemies and by improving your resilience
you can Trek through deserts and
volcanoes I'm happiest when I'm in the
gym or when I'm learning a new
programming language because that's when
I'm training that's when I'm growing and
that's when life is less of a boring
daily grind and more akin to of being a
warrior or
when people ask me why I work out the
best reason I can give is that so if I
ever met Batman we'd have something in
common
I think life should be an adventure and
I see no reason why it can't be thanks a
ton for hearing me out guys hope you
found that interesting and maybe a
little bit inspiring if you did please
consider liking and sharing this video
maybe leave a comment down below in the
comment section and I'll try and get
back to you perhaps consider follow me
on Twitter and Facebook I post my
workouts and my daily work etc on there
so you can see that and yeah I've got
plenty more like this on the way more
training videos more philosophy
psychology neuroscience transhumanism
technology working out you name it so
stay tuned and I'll see you for the next
one thanks for much for watching and bye
for now